C++ is either Charmander or Charmeleon, whereas Circle is Charizard. And like, that's the thing, I know about Charizard because it was one of the cards that everyone was after. Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, episode 129, recorded on May 10th, 2023. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we chat about the exciting new pipeline operator that is implemented in the most recent release of Circle. I did. I did reach out to and get a reply from the special guest that you have been desiring. We can tell the listener. No, no, no. We're not going to say it yet.
C++ 要么是小火龙，要么是火恐龙，而 Circle 就像是喷火龙。事情就是这样，我知道喷火龙是因为它是每个人都想收集的卡片之一。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 129 期，录制于 2023 年 5 月 10 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的共同主持布莱斯（Bryce）一起，聊聊 Circle 最新版本中实现的令人兴奋的新管道操作符。我确实联系了你一直想要的那位特邀嘉宾，并且得到了回复。我们可以告诉听众。不，不，不。我们现在还不能说。
We're not going to say it yet. Can we say what the project was, though? Because this was a listener request. Okay, we won't mention the project, but there's an exciting new project. People can put it together. And someone requested it. If you are that person, we did reach out to a person involved. We won't say how important they were.
我们现在还不能说。不过能说说是什么项目吗？因为这是一个听众的要求。好吧，我们不提具体项目，但有一个令人兴奋的新项目。大家可以猜猜。而且有人提出了这个要求。如果你就是那个人，我们确实联系了相关人员。我们就不说他们有多重要了。
But they are a little bit pressed for time, correct? But we're going to – we got a reply. And we're going to circle back in a couple weeks or months, and I think eventually it'll happen. Perfect segue. We're going to circle to circle. I'm not sure if you have a topic to talk about today, but we could spend the whole next 30 minutes that you have talking about the latest and greatest features in Circle. I do have to warn you that the dog and the girlfriend is going to come back at some point, and noise is going to be made. That's all right. We can record one episode now, and we'll set something up next week.
但他们最近确实比较忙，对吧？不过我们要——我们收到了回复。我们会在几周或几个月后再跟进，我想最终这会实现的。完美的过渡。我们转回 Circle。我不确定你今天有没有什么话题要聊，但我们可以把你所有的那整整 30 分钟都用来聊聊 Circle 最新、最棒的功能。我得提醒你，狗和女朋友随时可能会回来，到时候会发出噪音。没关系。我们现在可以录制一集，下周再安排别的。
All right, but so I'm not going to screen share. We're just going to talk about it because we don't screen share anymore. People that follow me on Twitter, and I think actually I mentioned this last episode that... All two of them. So funny, Bryce. We get it. You got more Twitter followers than most people. And I mentioned it last episode that Sean Baxter,
好吧，不过我不打算共享屏幕。我们只是聊聊，因为我们不再共享屏幕了。在 Twitter 上关注我的人——我想我在上一集其实提到过……才两个人。太搞笑了，布莱斯。我们懂的。你的 Twitter 粉丝比大多数人都多。我在上一集提到过，肖恩·巴克斯特（Sean Baxter），
the man, the myth, the legend behind the Circle C++ compiler, was working on implementing the pipeline operator along with the placeholder. That is now complete. It is now available on Godbolt. And it's never been a more exciting time. I don't even want to say in C++ because this isn't C++. This is Circle. Circle.
Circle C++ 编译器背后的那个男人、神话、传奇，一直在致力于实现管道操作符以及占位符。现在已经完成了。现在可以在 Godbolt 上使用了。从来没有比现在更让人兴奋的时刻了。我甚至不想说是在 C++ 领域，因为这不是 C++。这是 Circle。Circle。
I think Circle, it doesn't have a logo. So you don't think post-release of C++11 was a more exciting time? I wasn't programming in C++ back then. I didn't start programming in C++ until 2000. Back in mod day, we didn't have no variadic templates. We had to stamp those out by hand. And you know what? We were happy about it.
我觉得 Circle 连个标志都没有。所以你认为 C++11 发布之后没有更让人兴奋的时刻了吗？我那时候不写 C++。我直到 2000 年才开始写 C++。在过去的日子里，我们可没有变长模板（variadic templates）。我们得亲手把它们敲出来。你知道吗？我们对此乐此不疲。
I don't think people were. I don't think people were. Nobody was happy about it. But it got the job done. You know that's how that used to work, like, pre-C++11? Like, if you wanted to do something variadic template, like the the person who wrote the library they would just stamp out all the overloads and normally there would be
我不觉得大家乐在其中。我不觉得大家是这样的。没有人会对此感到高兴。但它确实能解决问题。你知道以前 C++11 之前是怎么运作的吗？比如说，如果你想搞什么变长模板，写库的那个人就得把所有的重载全部手写出来，通常还会用上一些
some pre-processor magic and you would you would you would define some macro that would say how many up to what already do you want it to support and and as you went to higher rd of course compile time would get slower and slower that's how that worked that's unfortunate but uh the improvement upon that in c++ 11 was not as exciting as this i i agree i think circles the most exciting thing yeah what's exciting about this is like this is a proposal that i was told by zach lane was dead in the water that makes me sad because this rust traits thing is is not going to entirely supersede what would have been possible with this pipeline operator. And now I offhandedly mention it to Sean.
预处理器的魔法，你会定义某个宏来指明你希望它支持到第几个参数，随着参数层级越高，编译时间自然就会变得越来越慢，以前就是这样的。这挺不幸的，但是……C++ 11 对此的改进并没有这个让人兴奋。我同意，我觉得 Circle 才是最让人兴奋的。是的，最让人兴奋的是，扎克·莱恩（Zach Lane）曾告诉我这个提案已经彻底泡汤了。这让我挺难过的，因为这个 Rust 特性（traits）并没有完全取代这个管道操作符本来可以实现的功能。而现在我随口向肖恩提了一下，
I wouldn't say I was trying to nerd snipe him, but I did make a comment being like, I'll basically turn all my C++ talks over the next two months into circle talks if you can make this happen. Poof, three days later, he has it basically working. And then less than a week later he's got an instance of it on godbolt that people can play around with and it also works
我不会说我是想用“书呆子狙击”（nerd snipe）来难倒他，但我确实评论过类似这样的话：如果你能把这个实现出来，我基本上会把我接下来两个月所有的 C++ 演讲都变成 Circle 演讲。结果，噗，三天后他基本上就把它弄好了。然后不到一周的时间，他就把实例放到了 Godbolt 上，供大家尝鲜，而且它还完美支持
with c++ 23 works with all the libraries it's absolutely phenomenal and so you're gonna revive this proposal and also i gotta say sean brilliant guy so easy to nerd snipe so easy to nerd snipe i mean this is like uh it's nerd sniping but also too like i'm thinking about there's a couple internal projects that i'm working at in nvidia and i'm using c++ 23 how how amazing is it that like like c++ programmers have been conditioned for so many years that a new feature takes years to deliver to you. And then you go to Sean and you're like, hey, Sean, could you implement this thing? And it's like three days later, he's like, yeah, here, this is done. Yeah, it's phenomenal. But does that say more about Sean or about the stagnation state of c++ compilers than it does about any any particular
C++ 23，支持所有的库，绝对太牛了。所以你要让这个提案复活，而且我必须得说，肖恩真是个天才，太容易被“书呆子狙击”了。太容易被“书呆子狙击”了。我的意思是，这就像是……这不仅是书呆子狙击，而且我也在想，我在英伟达（Nvidia）正在参与几个内部项目，我正在使用 C++ 23。这有多神奇啊——C++ 程序员被长期灌输的一种观念是，一个新功能需要好几年才能交到你手上。然后你去找肖恩，对他说，嘿，肖恩，你能实现这个功能吗？结果大概三天后，他就说，行了，这写好了。对，这太惊人了。但这与其说是说明了肖恩的水平，或是说明了 C++ 编译器停滞不前的现状，倒不如说它说明了任何特定的
special you know uh thing about him or circle i think it's obviously both i mean i don't think you would disagree that uh if sean is listening maybe he'll interested to hear his thoughts on this but sean strikes me as like a savant level like he operates at a very very high level i agree i agree but at the end of the day he is he is just one man and if one man even a savant level man like sean can make a compiler where he can so rapidly implement new features in unlike like three days versus the you know years that it would take for and and to be fair i think it was actually more like 24 hours and then the extra 48 hours was like him asking me for test cases and then he ran into like two or three bugs and then by ran into two or three bugs.
特殊……你知道的……关于他或 Circle 的事情。我觉得显然两方面都有。我的意思是，你大概不会否认……如果肖恩在听的话，也许他会有兴趣听听他对这事的想法。但肖恩给我的感觉就像是个学者/天才级别的人物——他的运作水平非常非常高。我同意，我同意。但归根结底，他只是一个人。如果一个人，哪怕是像肖恩这样天才级别的人，也能做出一个编译器，能够以仅仅三天左右的速度迅速实现新功能，与之对比的是需要耗时好几年——而且说实话，我觉得实际情况更像是 24 小时，然后额外的 48 小时是他向我索要测试用例，接着他遇到了两三个 Bug，然后在一边遇到两三个 Bug 的同时……
And then by the end of that three-day period, he was basically finished. Right. And then just waiting for some PRs to get pushed through on Gobbolt. I think that this says a lot about the state of the clang in GCC and MSVC code bases. And it's not to say that there aren't there aren't brilliant folks working on uh those three different compilers but like i have to say like i have
然后在那个三天周期的结束时，他基本上就大功告成了。没错。然后就等几个 PR 在 Godbolt 上合并推送了。我觉得这很能说明 Clang、GCC 和 MSVC 代码库现状的问题。这并不是说那三个不同编译器的开发人员里没有才华横溢的高手，但……我不得不说，我
not been more excited about the people it's about it's about the code bases and it's about the process yeah but just like having this i had been in the back of my head thinking about like oh yeah it'd be really cool because i i have a pretty clear idea of I've already got probably 50 to 75 percent of my C++ talk done. And I've had the idea of what I wanted to do for, you know, since basically the beginning of the year when I started submitting talks or proposals. And I had thought in the back of my head, it would be really cool if I could have an actual working compiler to link people to the possible version of the solutions to these problems I'm going to be showing with the pipeline. But like, the only way that that's possible is through Circle. There's no way that MSVC, GCC, or Clang, unless if I forked Clang myself and did my own compiler hackery, but
从来没有对……这其实不是人的问题，而是代码库的问题，是流程的问题。是的，但就是有这个想法一直在我脑海里盘旋，因为我有一个相当清晰的想法——我已经完成了大概 50% 到 75% 的 C++ 演讲内容。从今年初我开始提交演讲或提案的时候起，我就已经有了我想做什么的想法。我一直在脑子里想，如果我能有一个真正能运行的编译器，好把可能实现的解决方案版本的链接分享给来看我用管道符展示这些问题的人，那该有多酷啊。但问题是，唯一实现这一点的途径就是通过 Circle。MSVC、GCC 或 Clang 根本不可能做到这一点——除非我自己去 Fork 一下 Clang，然后自己搞编译器魔改，不过
Lord knows... We'll link in the description, show notes. I'm not going to remember his name, but he, I believe, lives in Israel, and he gave a talk at CppCon 2019, and he implemented concepts, and he just... I will now
天知道……我们会在描述和节目笔记中放上链接。我不记得他的名字了，但他好像住在以色列，他在 CppCon 2019 上做过一次演讲，他实现了概念（concepts），然后他只是……我现在要
attempt to nerd snipe anybody here who's a clang developer i believe that clang is is great if you think that clang is so great and if you think that circle is just a bunch of hot air then one of you goes go implement the pipeline operator in 24 hours and you get an extra 48 hours for bugs and tests. Go do it. You know what? You can even all team up. A group of you can go do it. I dare you to go do it in Clang.
尝试去“书呆子狙击”这里任何一个 Clang 开发者。我认为 Clang 非常棒。如果你觉得 Clang 那么厉害，如果你觉得 Circle 只是夸夸其谈，那你们当中有谁去在 24 小时内把管道操作符在 Clang 里实现出来，你们可以有额外的 48 小时来处理 Bug 和测试。去干吧。你知道吗？你们甚至可以组团去。你们中的一群人可以去搞定它。我敢你们去在 Clang 里实现它。
I dare somebody. You get three days to go and implement this thing see if you can do it you know what it has me thinking now too is this is a feature that um i think for a while you didn't care about but then once you started using some ranges stuff you were like oh we need this and i was like i told you that like three years ago was the uh the papers called polymorphic lambdas with structure bindings or something that like that They don't call them generic lambdas. They call them polymorphic lambdas for some reason. Somebody once told me that the mark of a smart person is their willingness to rapidly change
我敢任何人来试试。给你三天时间去实现这个功能，看看你能不能做到。你知道吗，这现在也让我想到，这是一个功能……我想你有一段时间并不在意，但一旦你开始使用一些 ranges（范围）的东西，你就觉得：哦，我们需要这个。当时我就说：我三年前就跟你说过这个了。那篇论文叫作带有结构化绑定（structure bindings）的多态 Lambda（Polymorphic lambdas），或者类似这样的东西。他们不叫它们泛型 Lambda。不知为什么，他们管它们叫多态 Lambda。有人曾经告诉我，聪明人的标志就是当他们意识到自己错了时，
their position when they realize they're wrong. Flexibility of thought. And I flip-flop like the best of them. Yep. But like now, that's got me thinking because there's this one code example. I actually haven't modified it to get it working but it's actually it's an example that barry uses in his proposal uh the iso c++ paper and that that solution will be enhanced even a little bit more if we have that uh generic lambdas with uh structure bindings so that you can unpack it right in the parameter list.
愿意迅速改变立场。思想的灵活性。而我像最擅长此道的人一样反复横跳。没错。但现在，这让我开始琢磨，因为有一个代码示例。我其实还没修改它来让它运行起来，但这其实是巴里（Barry）在他的提案中——即 ISO C++ 论文中——使用的一个例子。如果我们有了那个带有结构化绑定的泛型 Lambda，使得你可以直接在参数列表中解构它，那么那个解决方案将会得到进一步的增强。
Yes. And like now I'm thinking like, I don't even know if that's possible. Like I think some things need to be figured out, but now I'm, Sean, if you're listening, if you need something else. Please, Sean. And now this just makes me think like I have,
是的。而现在我想的是，我甚至不知道这是否可行。我觉得有些事情还需要琢磨清楚，但现在我……肖恩，如果你在听的话，如果你还需要点别的什么……拜托了，肖恩。而这让我觉得我有……
Sean doesn't have time to listen to this podcast. We can safely say whatever we want about Sean. He's not listening. But the point is, is like I'm just over the moon that now, not only do I have access to this and I can use it, but like I basically, my talk is going to be a C++ talk for like the first two examples. And then I'm just going to switch.
肖恩才没时间听这个播客。我们可以放心地对肖恩畅所欲言。他没在听。但关键是，我简直欣喜若狂，因为现在不仅我能接触到这个并能使用它，而且……基本上，我的演讲在头两个例子里会是 C++ 演讲。然后我就会直接切换过去。
I've even made my own circle logo. But circle is C++. It is, but C++ doesn't get me this excited. Yeah, but I want to drive this point home because I think this is a point that Sean would make. Circle is not a successor language to C++. It's not trying to be a different language. Circle is trying to chart a better path forward for C++ and specifically a better path forward for how we develop and evolve C++ would be better off if we just appointed Sean the dictator of C++. And we just closed up the ISO shop. And, you know, just the future evolution of C++ was all done through Circle.
我甚至自己做了一个 Circle 的 logo。但 Circle 不就是 C++ 吗？是的，但 C++ 可没让我这么兴奋。对，但我想强调这一点，因为我觉得这是肖恩会指出的一个点：Circle 并不是 C++ 的继承语言。它并不是想成为一种不同的语言。Circle 试图为 C++ 规划一条更好的前进道路，特别是为我们如何开发和演进 C++ 提供一条更好的前进道路。如果我们直接任命肖恩为 C++ 的独裁者，然后关掉 ISO 的店铺，并且……你知道的，让 C++ 的未来演进全部通过 Circle 来完成，
And Circle was the official reference language. But what Sean really means by that, when he says that Circle is C++ is that it's, you know, it's extensions and proposals to C++, but that it's all built on top of C++ itself. That it's not meant to be a new language, it's not meant to be a thing from scratch. That he feels that it's not not meant to be a new language it's not meant to be a thing from scratch um that he feels that it's important um and also he feels that that we can't evolve c plus plus into a better language and he's trying to show us how to do that and he thinks that that's a better idea than going and building these successor languages. So I went and looked up Pokemon Evolution because I wasn't allowed to follow Pokemon or watch it
而 Circle 成为官方的参考语言，那么 C++ 可能会变得更好。但肖恩对此的真正含义——当他说 Circle 就是 C++ 时——是指它（你知道的）是对 C++ 的扩展和提案，但这一切都是建立在 C++ 本身之上的。它并不是要成为一种新语言，也不是要从头开始搞个新东西。他觉得……这并不是要成为一种新语言，也不是要从头开始搞个新东西，嗯……他觉得这很重要，而且他也觉得我们无法把 C++ 演进成一种更好的语言，他正试图向我们展示该怎么做。他认为这比去构建那些继承语言要好得多。于是我去查了宝可梦的进化，因为以前不被允许玩宝可梦或看它，
or have the card story for a different day. Yeah, you had an interesting childhood. But so I'm not sure if Charmander is like pre-C++11 and then Charmeleon is like C plus plus 11 slash 20 like all the new additions but like charizard is definitely circle it's like so that's that's what i mean is that like i don't want to put a c plus plus logo in the top corner of my circle code because c plus plus is either charmander or charmelian whereas circle is And, like, that's the thing. I know about Charizard because it was one of the cards
也不能收集卡片——这是另一个故事了。对，你有一个有趣的童年。不过我不确定小火龙是不是就像是 C++11 之前，然后火恐龙就像是 C++11/20 时代——也就是所有的新增特性，但喷火龙绝对就是 Circle。所以，这就是我的意思：我不想在我的 Circle 代码的右上角放一个 C++ 的标志，因为 C++ 要么是小火龙，要么是火恐龙，而 Circle 则是喷火龙。事情就是这样。我知道喷火龙是因为它是每个人都想要
that everyone was after. I couldn't... Not in a million years would I have been able to tell you Charmander and Charmeleon. Like, I know Pikachu and Bulbasaur. I mean, Charmander's pretty good, I gotta say.
的卡片之一。我绝不可能……哪怕给我一百万年，我也认不出小火龙和火恐龙。我知道皮卡丘和妙蛙种子。不过，小火龙确实挺不错的，我得承认。
Like, you know, he was pretty good back in the day. Back in the day. But now... And so that's the thing, is I just... I know that Circle was C++. Because, like, he's, like,
就像，你知道的，他当年挺厉害的。当年。但现在……所以事情就是这样，我只是……我知道 Circle 就是 C++。因为，他就像是
good against, like, the first couple of gym bosses. I think in the original games, I think Squirtle was really the one that struggled. Yeah, I mean, I know Squirtle is the little toad looking one, right? No, no, no. Maybe it was... Where's that Bulbasaur? Maybe it was the grass one.
对付前几个道馆馆主很厉害。我觉得在最初的游戏中，杰尼龟（Squirtle）才是那个真正苦苦挣扎的。对啊，我知道杰尼龟是那个长得像小癞蛤蟆的对吧？不，不，不。也许是……妙蛙种子在哪？也许是那个草系的。
Anyways, one of them had difficulty against the first few gym bosses. The point is, Charizard, aka Circle, is the evolved C++. And so even though they are the same thing in some respects, and I think that's how sean wants to market it is like this has me so excited now and like although i i will say i sean is not somebody who does marketing sean sean is telling you genuinely what he thinks and believes i've i've never heard a man with less bullshit in me. Okay, I'm sure. And I say that as a person with a great deal of bullshit in me. I knew how that sentence was going to end. And I say that. Fill in the blank.
总之，其中有一个在对付前几个道馆馆主时很吃力。重点是，喷火龙，也就是 Circle，是进化后的 C++。所以尽管它们在某些方面是一样的，我想这也是肖恩想要推广它的方式——这让我现在超级兴奋，而且虽然我要说的是，肖恩可不是那种搞营销的人，肖恩向你表达的是他内心真正的想法和信念。我从来没听过哪个家伙满嘴跑火车的成分这么少。好吧，我确信。而且我是作为一个满嘴跑火车成分相当高的人说这话的。我早就知道那句话会怎么结尾。而我说的是……请填空。
Oh, I have a dog. And she's going to come right over to me right now. Yes, she is. She has to say hi. Because she just went outside. All right. Let's wrap up wherever this is going. So what did you want to talk about?
哦，我有一只狗。它现在就要朝我走过来了。是的，它要。它得打个招呼。因为它刚从外面回来。好了，不管这个话题要飘到哪去，我们做个总结吧。所以你想聊点什么？
I mean, just basically announcing that there will be links in the description for folks that want to go check this out. And in general, it just has me more excited about, like, I think last episode i said using some of the other features like language tuples and variants would have me a little bit concerned because then it becomes like a lot less compatible with like existing c++ compilers and now i'm thinking to myself what what version of me is saying that like i want language tuples why why do i even care if i'm if i'm veering a little bit away from C++ if I'm just going to be compiling with Circle? Anyways, the point is Circle's amazing and super excited about it. Yeah.
我的意思是，基本上就是宣布节目描述里会提供链接，供想要去了解的朋友们查看。总的来说，这让我更加兴奋——我觉得上一集我说过，使用语言元组（language tuples）和变体（variants）等其他特性会让我有点担忧，因为那样一来，它与现有 C++ 编译器的兼容性就会大大降低。而现在我在想：我到底在用哪个版本的我在说话啊？我为什么会想要语言元组？如果我要用 Circle 来编译，那稍微偏离一点 C++，我到底还在乎个啥？总之，重点是 Circle 太神奇了，对此我超级兴奋。Yeah。
So stay tuned, folks. My C++ talk is now a Circle talk. Thank you to Sean. Super excited. And also, too, like I don't mean to say this, too, that like, you know, C++ is done. Like I think the folks in the C++ ISO committee should be like... I know that the template metaprogramming group, which I think actually is temporarily shut down from what I've heard. I mean, I don't
所以各位请拭目以待。我的 C++ 演讲现在变成 Circle 演讲了。感谢肖恩。超级兴奋。而且话说回来，我这么说并不是在暗示 C++ 已经完蛋了。我觉得 C++ ISO 委员会的人应该……我知道模板元编程小组——我听说它实际上已经暂时解散了。我的意思是，我并不
really follow the ISO ins and outs. Well, I mean, honestly, no. But I mean, your point about you're not saying that C++ is done, I mean, I think that's Sean's whole point is that C++ isn't done, that the future of C++ should be
怎么关注 ISO 的内部运作。好吧，我是说，说实话，确实不关注。不过，你关于“你不是在说 C++ 已经完蛋了”的观点，我的意思是，我觉得这正是肖恩的核心观点：C++ 并没有完蛋，C++ 的未来应该是
circle, a point with which I wholeheartedly agree. I just, I feel like I'm going to be testing out all of my personal projects that I have, because I already was going to, I kind of was waiting for C++ 23 so I could just get rid of a lot of the range
Circle。这一点我举双手双脚赞成。我只是……我觉得我接下来要测试我所有的个人项目，因为我本来就打算这么做，我之前一直在等 C++ 23，这样我就可以摆脱我所依赖的很多 range-v3
V3 stuff that i was depending on and now that i'm doing that i just i feel like let's check let's check on circle laying do they have cmake um i would almost oh i googled cmake and it doesn't actually say anything but i imagine i mean if you can get this to work on the command line you can get this to work with CMake, correct? yeah, well as somebody who has spent some amount of time
的东西了。既然我正在这么做，我就觉得：让我们去看看 CMake 支不支持 Circle 吧？我几乎要……我 Google 了一下 CMake，结果其实没查到什么，但我想象着，如果你能在命令行里让它跑起来，你就能让它通过 CMake 跑起来，对吧？是的，好吧，作为一个花了一定时间
trying to get CMake to work with new compilers it's not trivial let's go to the github circle github Let's go to the GitHub. Circle, GitHub. Circle CI is the first thing that comes up. Sean. Have we ever done an episode where we talked about how we like to present?
试图让 CMake 配合新编译器工作的人，这可绝非易事。我们去 GitHub 上的 Circle 项目看看吧。让我们去 GitHub。Circle GitHub。排在第一位的是 Circle CI。肖恩。我们以前做过一期节目，聊过我们喜欢怎么做演讲吗？
Like at conferences? Yeah. I don't think so. We've done like meta conversations one of them came up with Sean Parent who we have to have on we apologize Sean I can't even when's the last time we've had him on it's been way too long
比如在会议上？对。好像没有吧。我们做过那种元对话，其中有一期提到了肖恩·帕伦特（Sean Parent），我们必须请他来做客。对不起啊，肖恩，我们上次请他来是什么时候了？已经过去太久了。
I don't know we're gonna reach out Sean we'll see if we can that's what we'll do he's at C++ now we're supposed to talk to Tristan Brindle oh yeah I gotta say because like He's at C++ now. We're supposed to talk to Tristan Brindle. We're going to have Tristan at home. Oh, yeah.
不知道，我们会联系肖恩的，看能不能……我们就这么办。他现在在 CppCon 呢。我们本来应该跟特里斯坦·布林德尔（Tristan Brindle）聊聊的。哦，对啊。我得说，因为……他现在在 CppCon。我们本来应该和特里斯坦·布林德尔聊聊的。我们在家里也能有特里斯坦。哦，对。
I got to say because, like, I am not at C++ now. Yeah. Okay. I'm not there this year. There's no particular reason. I just have a lot of travel. This one, this was the trip that got cut. But I am not there i'm getting like three or
我得说，因为……我没去 CppCon。是的。好吧，我今年没去。没有什么特别的原因。只是我有很多行程要跑。这一场，这就是那个被砍掉的行程。但我没去，我每天都会收到三、四条消息，
four messages a day from people being like hey where are you we're we're going to dinner or like other various inquiries it's like i'm fine i am not i am not in a hospital i am not sick it's just simply not at the conference. I feel very sad. Nobody's asked me why I'm not at the conference. You're not as important as me. It's clearly not. Clearly not. That's not true. I may be a more prominent person right now, Connor, my my velocity may be greater but your acceleration is definitely greater i feel like in 10 years from now i'm gonna be telling people oh yeah i knew connor
有人问：嘿，你在哪？我们要去吃晚饭啦。或者各种其他询问。我就想：我很好，我没进医院，我没生病，我只是单纯没去参加会议而已。我觉得好难过。没有人问我为什么没去开会。你没有我那么重要。显然没有。显然没有。才不是呢。我现在可能是一个更出名的人，康纳，我的发展速度可能更快，但你的加速度绝对比我更大。我觉得从现在起 10 年后，我会跟别人说：“哦，对啊，我认识康纳，
back when he was a little what do you what do you mean this this podcast is still gonna be happening you're gonna be telling people i know him we're still gonna be co-hosts buddy uh i i definitely will be telling people i know you do you tell people that you know me uh i mean people people just know that we know each other because most people that know that's true actually i mean i don't i don't know like because what are the circumstances where i'm at some event it's always a conference and typically the crowd at the conference except for c plus plus now which is a conference that i am not attending yeah i don't think i'll be ever ever be able to make it back unless if i skip because i am in the midst of three races two one that i had a couple days ago and one that i had a
早在他是那个小……你这话什么意思？这个播客还会继续办下去的呢！你会跟别人说“我认识他，我们还是联合主持人呢，老兄”。我……我绝对会跟别人说我认识你。你会跟别人说你认识我吗？我的意思是，大家……大家本来就知道我们认识，因为大多数人……这倒也是真的。我的意思是，我不知道……因为在什么情况下我会去某个活动？通常都是会议。除了 CppCon 以外——那是一个我没有出席的会议——是的，我觉得我可能再也去不了了，除非我翘掉……因为我正处于三场比赛当中。一场是几天前刚比完的，一场是
week ago and then there's one on the 14th So like basically the conference is bookended by like two of my favorite races. Yeah. Anyways, back to us. So there are a couple issues on the Circle GitHub that are entitled. They're closed. So we can go read them. We'll link them in the show notes. Advice to replace G++ with Circle for CMake projects.
一周前比完的，然后 14 号还有一场。所以基本上，会议被我最喜欢的两场比赛给夹在中间了。好吧，言归正传。在 Circle 的 GitHub 上有几个被标记了 Issue 的议题。它们已经关闭了。所以我们可以去读读。我们会把它们放在节目笔记里。建议将 CMake 项目中的 G++ 替换为 Circle。
And there's been a couple other CMake fixes. So it looks like there is CMake support. Probably there should be a bullet point on the homepage that says something about that. It may not support all the flags, or it may not have built-in support for setting the features, and I don't know whether
还有其他一些 CMake 的修复。所以看起来确实有 CMake 支持。主页上可能应该加一个要点，说明一下这个。它可能不支持所有的标志，或者可能对设置特性的支持不是内置的，而且我不知道
Circle CUDA is fully supported by CMake and things like that. Yeah. But I'll be testing it out. So stay tuned listener. And yes, Sean, we'll have you on. What is it today? We can have both Sean's on. Wait, have we had
Circle CUDA 是否得到了 CMake 的完全支持之类的。不过我会去测试的。所以请听众们拭目以待。是的，肖恩，我们会邀请你来做客的。今天几号来着？我们可以把两个肖恩都请来。等等，我们请过
Sean Baxter on? Oh yeah. When you recorded in your apartment. We did a three-part episode. Which is so unfortunate because that I think is one of our best episodes of all time. But because you recorded in an apartment, it was super echoey. So, like, that's, like, one of our best episodes and one of our worst quality audio qualities. But it's still, I think, people loved it.
肖恩·巴克斯特上节目吗？哦，对。当你在公寓里录音的时候。我们做了一期分为三部分的节目。这太遗憾了，因为那绝对是我们有史以来最好的一期节目之一。但因为你是在公寓里录的，回音超级大。所以，那可以说是我们音质最差的一期，却也是最好的一期。不过我还是觉得大家都挺喜欢的。
It's just would have been amazing if. Well, this episode is not going to be one known for our audio. Like, I don't know how I sound right now. No, you sound decent. I mean, it's not as crispy clear, but's like 60 70 is good so i'm gonna get a travel mic just so that wherever i am in the world i can always can always do something yeah and uh yeah we'll have sean we'll reach out and so yeah what, the date today is the 10th. We're releasing this.
只是要是当时……好吧，这一集可不会以我们的音质著称。我不知道我现在的声音听起来怎么样。不，你听起来还行。我的意思是，没有那么清脆透亮，但差不多有 60%、70% 的好。所以我打算买个旅行麦克风，这样无论我身处世界的哪个角落，我都能随时录音。是的，我们会联系肖恩的。所以，今天日期是 10 号。我们发布这期节目的时间是……
Don't tell me that. I don't want to know that. This is getting released on the 12th. As far as my mind is concerned, it's the start of May. It's not May 10th. It's the start of May. I've still got a month ahead of me. Okay?
别告诉我。我不想知道。这集要在 12 号发布。在我脑子里，现在才刚到五月。才不是 5 月 10 号。这才是五月的开头。我前面还有一个月的时光呢，好吗？
Glad we're all on the same page. Oh, yeah. We probably, let's see if we can record with either tristan and ben so we're gonna have a just to let the listener know we got to record we got to record next week because then i got my mom in town um so let's do well we we have to record like i guess we're gonna to record in Slovenia. Yeah, well, let's try and do it early because I'll be in New York Wednesday to Saturday, so I can't do it then. And once again, to clarify, you are not coming to see me, even though you, my closest friend, are coming to New York. I'm going to Montauk. Instead?
很高兴我们看法一致。哦，对。我们大概……让我们看看能不能跟特里斯坦或本（Ben）录音。所以我们要去……让听众们知道，我们下周得录音，因为接下来我妈要来镇上。所以我们得……好吧，我们得录音，我想我们得在斯洛文尼亚录音。对，好吧，我们尽量早点搞定，因为我周三到周六要在纽约，所以那时我录不了。再次澄清，你不是来看我的，尽管你这个我最亲密的朋友要来纽约。我要去蒙托克（Montauk）。而不是来找我？
I'm going to Montauk. You can come to Montauk. Instead. I'm going to Montauk. Instead. You can come to Montauk. Oh, at the last New York C++ meetup, I told multiple people about your trip to Montauk and the ridiculous mechanisms by which you are using to get from the airport to Montauk, and everybody agreed that... Hey, it's not my fault.
我要去蒙托克。你可以来蒙托克。而不是。我要去蒙托克。而不是。你可以来蒙托克。哦，在上次纽约 C++ 聚会上，我跟好几个人提到了你的蒙托克之行，以及你从机场去蒙托克所采用的那些荒谬的交通方式，每个人都一致认为……嘿，这又不是我的错。
Google Maps said there was no transit to the Gurney Resort, and I didn't think to change the location. As my girlfriend will happily tell you, you should not rely on Google Maps as much as you do. What? What else should I rely on? I don't know. Common sense? I thought you were going to say me, Connor.
Google 地图上说去格尼度假村（Gurney's Resort）没有公共交通，而我当时没想到去更改位置。正如我女朋友会高兴地告诉你的那样，你可不能像现在这样过度依赖 Google 地图。什么？那我该依赖什么？我不知道。常识？我还以为你要说我呢，康纳。
You should have asked me. No. Connor, you should have asked me. No, I used to think I had an excellent sense of direction, but I didn't know I was clumsy, and I didn't know that I didn't have an excellent sense of direction. These are things that I feel like your parents should tell you, but I did not learn those until recently, and I have no table manners. We live, we learn.
你应该问我的。不。康纳，你应该问我的。不，我以前以为自己有极佳的方向感，但我不知道自己其实很笨拙，也不知道自己其实并没有极佳的方向感。这些事情我觉得你父母应该早点告诉你，但我直到最近才意识到这些，而且我连餐桌礼仪都没有。活到老，学到老。
Yes. Yeah. We're going to see each other lots, though. We're going to see each other for like a week. Also, yeah. I still have to book hotels. But that is, yes. I'm working on finalizing the travel plans.
对啊。不过我们接下来会经常见面的。我们要连续待好几天呢。还有，对。我还没订酒店。不过那是……是的。我正在敲定行程计划。
Yeah. I haven't booked half of my hotels. I got all my flights booked finally just like a couple days ago. Almost messy. Who are you flying out of Venice? I'm going to Dublin, so I'm pretty sure there was only two options that were direct. One was Ryanair and one was Aer Lingus, and the Aer Lingus one was – Please, please tell me you took the Aer Lingus one yeah I I've heard okay I've heard that Ryanair is kind
对。我还有一半的酒店没订呢。我直到几天前才终于把所有的机票都订好了。差点就一团糟了。你是从威尼斯飞的吗？我要去都柏林，所以基本上直飞航班只有两个选择，我挺确定的。一个是瑞安航空（Ryanair），一个是爱尔兰航空（Aer Lingus），而爱尔兰航空的那班是——求求你告诉我你选的是爱尔兰航空的那班。对，我……我听说过，我听说瑞安航空有点
of the equivalent of flare I'm not sure if you've heard of that airline but I like to say if you don't care fly flare yeah um but honestly it was more because of the time of day one of them was like eight in the morning the other one was at noon so so you took the eight in the morning one no i took the noon one okay well mistakes mistakes why you should i mean you should prefer to to take the first flight in the morning because it's delays accumulate throughout the day and also if you take the first flight in the morning or the like the last flight of the day then you get to spend like the full day at your destination if you travel in the middle of the day then like it's it's just a full transit day now if it's a full transit day if you're on like an eight hour flight that doesn't matter but if you're flying somewhere
类似于廉航之王（Flare）——我不知道你有没有听过那家航空公司，但我总是说：如果你不在乎服务，那就坐 Flare 吧。嗯，老实说，主要还是因为起飞时间。一班是早上八点，另一班是中午十二点。所以你选了早上八点的？不，我选了中午十二点的。好吧，失误，失误。为什么你应该……我的意思是，你应该优先选择早上最早的那趟航班，因为延误会在一整天里累积，而且如果你坐早上最早的航班或者一天中最晚的航班，你就能在目的地度过完整的一天。如果你在白天中间出行，那就基本上变成纯粹的赶路日了。如果这是一整天的赶路日，假设你坐的是八小时的飞机，那无所谓；但如果你飞的地方
that's like two or three hours away if you take the 8 a.m flight you get in like 10 11 and then like it's just like you you know had like a slightly late morning getting up whereas if you take the noon flight then like you just you've lost that whole day i don't know if i'd agree with that i'm just saying you denied yourself anyways anyways that that the air lingus flight Aer Lingus flight. I'm taking an 8 a.m. flight out of Venice to go to London Heathrow. My flight to New York is like at 5 p.m., but I'm going to go to some lounges. Anyways, I got to go. I'm so sorry. What were you saying about the Aer Lingus flight?
只有两三个小时远，如果你坐早上 8 点的飞机，你 10 点、11 点就能到，然后感觉就像是……你知道的，只是稍微起得比平时晚了一点点的上午；而如果你坐中午的航班，那你基本上就白白浪费了一整天。我不知道我是否同意这一点。我只是说，你剥夺了自己的时间。不管怎样，那班爱尔兰航空的航班——爱尔兰航空的航班。我要坐早上 8 点从威尼斯出发去伦敦希思罗的航班。我去纽约的航班大概在下午 5 点，但我打算去逛逛候机室。总之，我得走了。实在抱歉。你刚才说爱尔兰航空的航班怎么了？
Oh, no. I was going to say you told me not to take Ryanair, and the Aer Lingus one was the one at noon. So you're giving me conflicting – what do I do? Better airline at noon or worse airline at 8, you're giving me conflicting, you know, what do I do? Better airline at noon or worse airline at 8 a.m.? You made the correct decision. But the bigger problem is why are you booking flights without still, like, talking to me? You know, there's a short answer to this, Bryce. And it's because I've had literally book all my accommodation and travel on my list of things to do since back in March.
哦，没有。我是想说，你之前告诉我不要坐瑞安航空，而爱尔兰航空的那班刚好是中午的。所以你给我的建议是相互矛盾的——我该怎么做？中午更好的航空公司，还是早上 8 点更差的航空公司？你给我的建议是互相矛盾的，你知道的，我该怎么办？中午更好的航空公司，还是早上 8 点更差的航空公司？你做出了正确的决定。但更大的问题是，为什么你订机票之前都不跟我商量一下？布莱斯，这有个简短的回答。因为从三月份开始，我把“预订所有住宿和行程”塞满了我的待办事项清单。
And we're now – That's fair, it's now May 10th. And I just like, I'm so, it just, it doesn't take a ton of time, but it takes like a couple hours to book like a few different flights and look around. You know that I love playing. I know, but I procrastinate so much on it that like finally when it gets to like an 8 p.m. on a Monday and I'm like, okay, I'm actually going'm actually gonna do this i'm not gonna message you to then find out oh i can't let's do it tomorrow morning i would drop everything and just go do it now you might open up a few credit cards in the process okay i gotta go though all right it's been a blast we will yeah chat next week and uh all the
而现在——这倒也公道，现在已经是 5 月 10 日了。我只是觉得……这虽然不要花太多时间，但要花几个小时来订好几张不同的机票并四处比价。你知道我喜欢折腾。我知道，但我在这上面拖延得太厉害了，以至于当周一晚上八点钟到来时，我在想：好吧，我今天一定要把这事办了。我不会再发消息问你，然后发现“哦，我办不了，我们明天早上再弄吧”。我会放下手头的一切，马上就去搞定它。过程中你可能还会多开几张信用卡。好吧，我得走了。今天聊得很开心，我们下周再聊，各位
listeners have a good have a good week be sure to check your show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for any of the topics that we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave any thoughts, questions, or comments on today's episode. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
听众们，祝大家过个愉快的一周。请务必查看你的播客应用中的节目笔记，或者访问 ADSPthepodcast.com，了解我们在今天节目中提到的任何话题，以及通往 GitHub 讨论区的链接，你可以在那里留下对本期节目的任何想法、问题或评论。感谢收听，希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。